this entire film seems to have been
planned as an elaborate scheme to slowly
push the cast into going insane the
directors of The Blair Witch Project
gave the three cast members cameras
supplies for survival and a place to
meet up from there the three were
essentially left alone in the woods a
few scenes from the movie are from when
they were actually lost trying to figure
out the next meet-up Point oftentimes
the directors would secretly follow the
cast and break sticks or throw rocks
around the unknowing campers and every
once in a while if it was dark you see
this red beam and you knew it was it was
the hackson band of goons running around
again worse yet the directors gave them
less food every day to make them ragged
angry and more on edge and as the days
went on the filmmakers came up with new
ways to torture their actors and they
were setting up you know sound Loops of
babies crying and kids laughing outside
or ten and four in the morning basically
it was just us running through trees and
going nuts out there after eight days of
filming it's safe to say that the cast
no longer enjoys walks in the woods